wow very cool facility amazing
Auditorium I like how they have the
students in the back and like the cool
kids section up top it's a good look
um
but before I get started I wanted to
thank Hillsdale College especially the
administrators and the staff
for their incredible courage to defy the
popular consensus over the last couple
years I don't know if the students
realize
um how lucky they were to
have this opportunity to learn in person
and to not be subject to this
pharmaceutical regime that basically you
know the the college population of the
rest of the entire nation was subject to
Hillsdale is so unique in the fact that
they defied this
um big Pharma big government public
health expert consensus and
they didn't ask me to do a pitch but
your money is is well spent here
um it would have been so much easier for
them just to succumb to the demands of
the Michigan Governor
um two administrations one Republican
one Democrat
um and it speaks volumes that you
chartered an independent course and it
speaks to you know the mission of
Hillsdale College and that it's working
to create independent interesting
thinkers and successful people
um in the United States and I I was you
know doing some research on Hillsdale I
spent a lot of time in Washington DC
last seven eight years before I moved to
Florida and I knew about Hillsdale
College
um but I I'm actually I was shocked by
uh how difficult it is now to get into
Hillsdale I mean if you guys were a
stock on on the NASDAQ you'd be like one
of those blue chip uh with a lot of room
to run and I think Hillsdale is going to
become like basically the Harvard Yale
whatever you want to call it of the
Midwest on the trajectory is in so the
students here you're in you're in
amazing shape right now
so how did I find myself basically
spending the last few years diving down
this covet hysteria Rabbit Hole
um and
as a journalist I think one of the most
important qualities is you have to be
able to
challenge conventional narratives and
what we found was that that wasn't
really happening at all
and for me this journey from being
basically labeled a bioterrorist after
anything I said I mean I'm sure RFK Jr
has a similar experience and you know
they cancel campaigns against him
um but I feel like the the momentum is
turning in in the right direction
finally and
you know we can start by talking about
big Pharma and
these mRNA shots you know this tale of
power grabs corruption deceit and of
course it begins in Wuhan in January
.
um the Chinese government uploads this
Gene sequence to a database suddenly
Pfizer moderna are right there they win
this vaccine jackpot no one's really
asking any questions
um
was it because they had a superior
product or rather were they just having
the pieces in place to work the system
to their benefit
um
what's interesting about this is that
before the covet era moderna had never
brought apart a product to Market before
not a single product and this was
amazing to me when I researched this I
thought like maybe it was just fake news
or something but it is true and I was
pointing this out and they're like uh
you know they they just kind of like
figured it out and if you read these
um these stories about moderna
um in these Publications and these
science Publications it was all about
their human trial not even getting to
human trials like the rats were dying
when they injected them with this stuff
and suddenly you know January 2020 comes
around and moderna has it figured out
it's good to go but it wasn't just
um a moderna thing
um it was also a Pfizer thing you know
their partner
um bio in Tech had also never brought a
single product to Market
but they were backed by very influential
individuals who were terrific at doing
marketing campaigns and spinning the
narrative and this is where
we have this Fusion of you know big
government and big Pharma
call it what you want you call it the
uniparty the ruling class the Washington
DC establishment
um
in recent decades and years and months
and days we continue to see this Fusion
of big Pharma and big government
um corporatism and statism
it's resulted in this incredibly weird
scenario we find ourselves today where I
think of course like you know the the
coming graduates of Hillsdale who I just
met are going to have to make a
difficult decision you know whether you
want to become part of that system or
try to do something on your own and
there's positives and negatives to each
part of that but I think that
you know as proven by me being on the
stage after 99 of
the folks who hated my opinions in
January and through December of 2020 now
are very much on my side I think
um
you have this kind of like Newton's
third law effect where you have this
equal and opposite reaction
um and I hope to bring the the best out
of that
um
but I want to get back to this Pfizer
moderna thing because I think that it's
still not really
clear like what exactly happened and and
the power grab and the money grab and it
was just so you know I don't think that
we really were able to focus on it
because you know there was all this
hysteria happening you know people
people were getting sick and there was
just way too much on people's minds but
pharmaceutical companies were getting
very rich
Pfizer
had the federal government siphon off
100 billion dollars from the American
taxpayer last year in revenue and
um 31 billion of that was profit
and what's even more shocking is that
all of Pfizer's profit comes from these
pharmaceutical products that are
supposedly free and that they mandated
upon the population that if it wasn't
for
the covet era these companies would not
be making any money they would not be
able to buy other companies be able to
invest in other r d platforms that will
help them succeed in the future I mean
this was such a coup for these two
companies and
I want to just
give you a perfect example of the
hypocrisy so there's a 2020 interview
with Albert borla the CEO of Pfizer who
happens to be a horse doctor by the way
I don't know if many people know that
he's an equestrian veterinarian
so the times interviewer asks him
what about pricing and he goes the
vaccine should be free to all people and
he kind of like it you know he's he's a
clever salesman because like what does
that mean so the guy goes you know is it
is it are you giving it away like for
free and he goes no no no no we're gonna
we're gonna give it to governments but
we're going to charge the government so
he goes a very nominal value but our
intent is to ask governments that they
should for these prices they should
provide it free of charge for all
citizens so they're just gonna Rob the
taxpayer blind but deliver it free of
charge
um
and then the the interviewer says so are
you essentially selling it to
governments at cost and he goes no you
know I think we'll make a profit but a
marginal profit and now we just see
Pfizer's filings last month that they
made 100 billion dollars in Revenue last
year half of that being almost half of
that being profit and of course the
profit comes from you the American
taxpayer
um and it's only made possible through
its you know the big form of big
government Nexus
um I've reported on Pfizer's tax filing
since the beginning of this era and
every single time you know
they're banking tens of billions of
dollars per quarter and people are just
like yeah you know they saved the world
so it's fine but
I think as this um
this quote-unquote emergency winds down
you can expect Pfizer deposit pivot
elsewhere
um I think that they've already kind of
started on that path they're now
introducing RSV vaccines for pregnant
women
um so they're getting into all kinds of
things uh moderna wants you to take a
shot now that you inject directly into
your heart so they're very ambitious and
I think like there's a real disconnect
between
what the corporate press is telling them
and these government partners are
telling them and how the people really
feel about them
um and I think you saw this at the world
economic Forum in Davos
earlier this year where you had a lot of
good reporters like from Rebel news and
elsewhere that were kind of like really
laying into them and the the CEO Pfizer
was pretty shocked and like unable to
answer these questions
um so I think that the tide is
definitely turning
um
and if we want to talk about moderna
it's really the same thing you know they
didn't make as much money but they have
an incredible since their founding in
2010 they've been interlinked with the
federal government in ways that still
kind of remain
unexplained
um
you know they their IPO they were
talking about curing cancer and other
types of disease they weren't talking
about making vaccines for coronaviruses
but people really seem to have not held
them accountable and you have this weird
thing in the pharmaceutical industry
that I'm sure RFK Jr talked about last
night where you have these repurposed
drugs like an ebola drug all of a sudden
becomes a coronavirus drug and none of
it really makes any scientific sense
when you look into it but then they just
start marketing it that way and it's all
good you know they just start selling it
um
by 2012 Moderno was a biotech uniform
unicorn raised a billion dollars on the
promise of the MRNA platform
uh DARPA got involved the defense
Advanced research projects agency
they gave hundreds of millions of
dollars fauci's National Institute for
allergy and infectious diseases also
they have confidential agreements they
got patents they got royalty deals the
U.S government has joined ownership of
the moderna vaccine
um and then there's something that we
can
talk about more broadly in a second but
we also have like this public private
Network Fusion which I think is best
exemplified by Bill Gates
um and the gates Network and the gates
Network's basically like its own
quasi-government entity
um and his people have been allowed to
have massive pre-ipo Equity investments
in moderna bio intact which again
partnered with Pfizer to make the shots
um and as
we have seen in the in the coming months
and years after that
um this man and his institutions have
used their influence to get their
products and their services in front of
the government
um
and I'm sure
there are some other companies and what
I'll touch upon in a second is like why
did we only have such few options why
was it only Modera Pfizer
Johnson and Johnson
and novovax which was way too late and
they're basically they're basically
bankrupt they're if you look at their
shares they're they're down 90 and
considering pulling the plug in the
whole company so this Gold Rush effect
was was so important for these companies
um Johnson and Johnson if you recall
um they were they were the third company
to receive clearance for their shot it
was an mRNA but what was interesting was
that there was a giant corporate press
campaign against Johnson and Johnson
um about specifically the safety and
efficacy of their shots
um supposedly like they were the only
one that was having the problems not
anyone else and it successfully like
this was like akin to a ruthless cartel
battle and Johnson and Johnson lost and
they kind of like retreated back into
the other space because Johnson and
Johnson like Pfizer they have other
products you know for moderna it's it's
all or nothing for Pfizer's bottom line
it's a very much All or Nothing for
Johnson and Johnson they can go back to
selling whatever they want to sell
um so they retreated there was a vicious
media campaign labeled
um they said that people were developing
you know deep vein thrombosis other
blood clotting disorders heart disorders
but it was only Johnson and Johnson
uh so my academic backgrounds in
international Affairs and foreign policy
so this why only four companies in the
United States making these shots is very
interesting to me especially when you
look at the what was happening around
the world
um and I know better to believe that the
nations of the world especially Fierce
adversaries Russia China U.S somehow
found like a Kumbaya moment and we all
got together you know the institutional
narrative is that we found a cure to the
coronavirus because there was this
Global effort to uh you know bring
everyone together and succeed for the
good of humanity but if you look at what
happened with these vaccine platforms
that's not at all what happened
um I think what we've really been
witnessing is a series of state-backed
big Pharma kind of like cartel fights uh
geopolitical information operations that
they're running against each other in
the United States it was very successful
we said mRNA is the best thing and then
everyone kind of believed that mRNA is
the best thing but that's not what they
say in China that's not what they say in
Russia
um
and if you look at the data there is no
clear real winner in my nine scientific
opinion I think that it's all trash so
uh
basically in the United States select
pharmaceutical companies were able to
seal off the market but in some
countries governments decided not to go
this route
for instance in Mexico they have access
to 10 different brands of shots in
Hungary they have 15.
um in other places like Iran turkey Cuba
and elsewhere they made their own thing
that they put in their citizens arms
they have their state you know there's
no separation between big Pharma and big
government they just tell the government
scientists hey make something and write
a paper that says it's 90 effective and
have people take it and then you're
cured you know you move on
um